bonsoir les suite des incidents
meurtriers de nouvelle calédonie et de
la prise en otage hier de 26 gendarmes à
l'issue d'un conseil restreint réuni par
le premier ministre à matignon le
ministre des dom-tom monsieur bernard
pons a immédiatement quitté paris en
début d'après-midi pour la nouvelle
calédonie où le fln kassa fait connaître
les conditions qu'il posait à la
libération des otages
parmi elles l'annulation des élections
territoriales dont les opérations
couplée avec celle de l'élection
présidentielle doivent commencer
incessamment puisque le jour et déjà
levé là bas la situation est très tendue
marie-odile bagneux d'importants
renforts de gendarmerie sont arrivés
aujourd'hui en nouvelle calédonie pour
maintenir l'ordre
au lendemain de l'attaqué meurtrière
d'ouvéa malgré cela de nombreux
incidents ont eu lieu sur la côte est à
canala des coups de feu tiré sur une
voiture ont blessé trois européens
leurs jours ne sont pas en danger
heineken les forces de l'ordre ont eu
recours aux gaz lacrymogènes pour
disperser des manifestants
indépendantistes qui ont riposté par des
jets de pierres
dans l'île d'ouvéa plus de 300 hommes
patrouillent toujours afin de localiser
les 27 gendarmes otages et leurs
ravisseurs
le fln k s a fait connaître les
conditions de leur libération
annulation des élections régionales qui
doivent débuter dans quelques heures
retrait des forces de l'ordre d'ouvéa et
nomination d'un médiateur
léopold ii g rodier l'un des dirigeants
indépendantistes a ajouté que si ces
conditions n'étaient pas respectées
le fln caisse mobiliserait pendant les
trois prochains mois pour forcer le
futur président de la république quel
qu'il soit à négocier